il ya une chose qui a beaucoup étonné
les occidentaux c'est la facilité avec
laquelle les talibans ont pris le
pouvoir en afghanistan et la rapidité
avec laquelle on a l'impression que le
peuple les attendait on a l'impression
que le peuple leur a ouvert les portes y
compris à kaboul oui bien sûr bon les
dunes par l'armée visiblement n'était
pas extraordinairement motive réellement
ya eu dernièrement forme et ça c'est une
chose président en place n'a pas été
très courageux le président a fait
preuve d'une couardise abominable s'est
enfui il s'est enfui j'ai appris par des
sources de kaboul les circonstances dans
lesquelles ça s'est passé parce qu'à un
moment donné les talibans ont envoyé un
message disant on n'est d'accord pour
rester à l'extérieur de kaboul bon
kaboul était un peu comme un fruit mûr
prêt à tomber et à subir une bataille la
dernière bataille et mais en disant vous
donne des garanties pour votre sécurité
on peut engager d'ores et déjà des
pourparlers pour le fameux gouvernement
inclusif dont on parle ce qui
permettrait de sauver la face peu et de
présenter un gouvernement qui ne serait
pas que tu aliments et il était à ce
moment là en train de déjeuner le
président avec un certain nombre de ses
collaborateurs
il a à ce moment là blêmit quittait la
table et s'est réfugié dans une autre
pièce sous prétexte qu'il avait mal à la
tête et qui voulait se reposer pendant
20 minutes 20 minutes pendant lesquelles
il a demandé à ce qu'on nomme embarque
un certain nombre de grosse valise qui
contenait 169 millions de dollars sans
souffle en 1169 millions de dollars en
billets de banque et les parties à
l'aéroport et comme l'avion ne pouvait
pas contenir tous tes valises jeune
parti qui est resté sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport et quelqu'un m'a dit que
témoin visuel
avait rapporté avec 45 millions de
dollars sur le tarmac